[Music]
here's Irving get this he's going
against a two-time all defensive player
in through the holiday and he makes it
just look so easy takes his time to step
back and just the fadeaway and it just
looks so effortless 12 10 lead for
Brooklyn of the floor in a hurry Ingram
spins nice help there from Allen the
turnaround goes Brandon Ingram is
scoring at will
Holliday up the floor whips it to the
outside nice step in Kyrie Irving the
steal triggers in a head on his hands
and they shot by Kyrie Irving coming
from behind to pick the pass get it
ahead and just thought elongated strive
by Karis levert allow him to cover
distance get ahead of the defender you
see there as true holiday tries to poke
it from behind
nice job get to the other side of the
rim
Ingram's all fake on allen pegs in a
hits chance at a three-point element of
Ingram he he even though he's a little
on the slender side and he still has
that Hank the that hype he still has
that length and the strength to be able
to go through this contact good pump
fake and just drums in there get to the
easy and still for 22 to play in the
opening quarter
Irving if there is one then you saw
ticket to the Detroit game 15-point lead
in the second half and then whatever you
want to call it ticket and foot off the
gas lethargic play relaxing as Dale
Harris gets the layup there they open
the window for the toy to get back to
the perfect lines adopted
buries it textbook form from Kyrie
Irving the patient's here's a textbook
form from Kyrie Irving from the
three-point line he always talks about
his elbow elbow being in when his shot
is on he's got his elbow in line you see
it there beautiful rotation Ingram has
been tremendous high off the window and
a chance for three hoop he gets to his
spot so well to mention his length and
just see the change of direction Okafor
would be underneath the basket and
instead Allen was there
Irving speeds
pop shooting practice love hurt got a
three
serving leading it Irving jabbed saved
money Kyrie Irving you see Kyrie work in
the work in the transition does a little
one-legged step back in pelicans do not
have a foul to give
curving and shoulder fake penetration to
the RAM made their last 11 shots of a
second quarter my riyer vaq violet
Ebanks at home and a foul
10 to shoot for Levert began his beats
holiday off the dribble
Irving Oh a deep three Kyrie Irving
almost at three feet behind the line but
really that all started with great ball
a nineties people at a very early age
you pick your feet up when your luck
airs Ingram norsu give it up Jackson
toilet pump
count it England crosses boy he is
nice tackle approach to what he's doing
against do his spots on the floor you
see the footwork his ability to shoot
over Jared Allen off that play but we've
seen us throughout the course
Kyrie Irving
a broom against prints faulty assignment
fancy dribbling and a fade he sticks it
his release point is so high
Irving splits defenders and finishes at
the rim 1:23 to 1:19 curve it fancy
dribbling fade book it always a pleasure
to watch Kyrie Irving to spin the bump
and sometimes you watch 1:28 1:21 des
[Music]
circles
things hits red and Ingram is putting on
a show under two minutes to play Ingram
crosses on Harris drives to the rim flip
shot goes what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content